i hit intros that time i got
reincarnated as a slime season two part
one
episode one rimaru is still kicking it
with the kids and he tells him that he
is going to be staying there until the
end of the term but then he is going
back to his new foundation they're all
kind of soon today
about it and then we get a new character
and professor tits who comes in to teach
the class in remaroo stat where you get
an unnecessary flashback of all the
things that happened in season one
rendering my job basically useless never
mind the flashback was actually super
vague i don't even know why they
bothered doing it to be honest
as you guys might remember from season
one rimaru had a little bit of a run in
with demon lord carrion don't worry
though they managed to work things out
and
signed a non-aggression pact not only
that but the juror tempest federation
and the animal kingdom of urazania
agreed to send delegates to one another
the
sexy ginger benny maru is appointed to
be the leader of the delegations with
rieger joining him as his assistant
rimaru makes a shitty speech and then
the delegates head out for demon
lorikarian's territory
once they had left all of the other side
characters start preparing for the
yarizanian delegates to arrive there
when the delegates arrive we meet my new
favorite character
and albie's the golden serpent joining
her on the delegation is the
confrontational
sufia the white tiger claw sofia starts
talking some mad [ __ ] about
humans and how rimuru should associate
with them because yom is a loyal
follower and a human also rimrou isn't
gonna let him get disrespected so he
gives him permission to fight sofia
luckily shion isn't taking this [ __ ]
either so she decides to fight in his
place to be fair she probably knew that
my boy was about to get his ass handed
to him while their little fight is going
on we meet gruesius who is a
biscuiteer's run
he is ordered by albies to fight with
yom instead so they get their fight
underway as well
episode 2 she only starts charging up a
maximum magic bullet and then alby steps
in to put an end to the fight the
delegates were testing rimaru and his
followers to see if they were worthy of
their respect
and since they passed in the fights they
can now sit as equals later on while
they're welcoming the guests properly we
learned that albies and sophia are kind
of alcoholics the two of them make a
deal with rima root to send fruit from
your lasagna because it's kind of known
for it and in exchange rimro agrees to
hook them up with some more alcohol
because reimaru isn't a trade expert he
doesn't know what the ratio should be
for the fruit to boost trade that's when
he has to call in the little puppers in
kobe who is a kobold merchant
this adorable little guy owns his own
shop in tempest
and is managing all of the merchants a
few days later the delegates left to
return to urazania we say that groceus
had received orders from phobia to stay
behind and help out in the tempest
nation the tempest delegates that went
to urazania also returned back home to
report back what they had found the
tempest nation was superior in a lot of
ways but one way that eurasania had
passed them
is in agriculture reimu decides that on
their next delegation they need to focus
on learning more about their agriculture
but in the meantime he's gonna head to
the dwarf kingdom
we also learned that benimaru had
challenged carrion to fight and lost
pretty badly meaning that carrion's
pretty [ __ ] strong
reimu then heads to wargo the dwarven
capital along with gopto gobzo
shunashion and kaijin squad once they
had arrived rimuru goes with a posse to
meet with king gazelle
before we see what goes on with that
though we hop over to clayman who is
having an interesting meeting he appears
to be forcing a new character in mulan
to spy
on the tempest nation episode 3 they
discussed the fact that the tempest
nation is well on its way to replacing
falmouth as the major trade center
although dwargo and falmuth are on good
terms with one another gazelle
warns rimeru that he doesn't like their
king the next day there's a declaration
made to the public saying that dwargo
and the tempest nation are now friends
that was pretty much all they needed to
handle and door goes so they get ready
to return back to the tempest nation
meanwhile the next day we see that yom
is approached by mulan
she's requesting to join their little
ragtag party and yom doesn't want to so
then they have a little skirmish to see
if she can prove herself and she wins
handily so the two end up becoming
friends
episode 4. reamer returns to the kids to
give them the results on their final
exams
all the kids pass or whatever who the
[ __ ] cares and then we see that gome and
mulan have arrived at the tempest nation
yum informs everybody that mulan is
going to be their new consultant and
military adviser to help them fight
against magic because apparently they're
lacking in that department
while talking with mule meyer we learned
that the tempest nation and blue men
have entered a security pact this means
that if blooming is going to be attacked
through the forest then the tempest
nation will have to step in
and in return if the tempest nation is
ever under attack then blumen will also
aid them
while rimaru is under the impression
that nobody's going to invade tempest
nation mulemire warns that falmouth
might not be too happy about them
becoming the new trade center this cues
us to hop on over to falmouth where we
see the king discussing things with his
subordinates
they discuss the rapidly expanding
tempest nation and decide that the best
time to strike them is now so they don't
have to compete with them for their
trade
this is when we meet the new character
archbishop rayheim who appears to have
some sort of plan
he says that the western holy church's
headquarters plans to subjugate the
nation of monsters
as an opposition of god and enemies they
plan to make it look like the tempest
nation had harmed one of their citizens
once that is the case the temple knights
will be able to head out and subjugate
the monsters
they plan to send some other worlders
ahead of the knights as a show of force
the three other worlders will be joined
by a hundred nights as an advance party
we get a look at the three other
worlders in shogu kirara and kyoya
episode five my boy yom is trying to get
in there with me ulam
and is making some pretty good progress
the next day milan is contacted by
clayman who has control of her heart and
is forcing her to do these things
because if she doesn't then he can kill
her he explains that he has one more job
for her and if she doesn't do it then
he's going to kill yom also
so i was doing some reconnaissance and
had noticed the falmouth knights
approaching the tempest nation
he reports this to the others but they
are still awaiting the return of rimaru
in the middle of their talk they are
then contacted by albies
she requests that the tempest nation
take in her people as refugees
this is because the kingdom of yerezania
is preparing to go to war with the demon
lord malim
the three other worlders arrive at the
tempest nation they were given the
orders by the king of falmouth to play
the victims of a tempest nation attack
kirora puts on support and level acting
to act like gobzo had grabbed her ass
and then threw her to the ground her
ability to bewilder allows her to make
everybody think that she's telling the
truth
gupta comes to his rescue and even
though he knows that gobzo is innocent
he still apologizes on his behalf
kirora is enraged that nobody believes
her so she tries using her bewilder
ability to order everybody nearby to die
usually this would cause everybody
nearby to drop dead but shuna and shion
show up negating the attack the two
sides get into a bit of a skirmish and
while that's going on we see that mulan
has been ordered by clayman to turn the
area into a non-magic area this will
allow them to cut the city's
communication off russia's had come
across mulan and confronts her saying
that she hasn't been acting right
she believes that the reason claiming as
asking her to cut off the communications
is because maleem had declared war
rimaru getting involved could be
problematic which is why he wants to
isolate them mulan takes on her true
form and grushas comes to the conclusion
that clayman is forcing her to do
something yum just so happens to be
passing by so he gets filled in on
everything happening he tells her that
he'll love her no matter what all that
good [ __ ] and then she knocks out the
communications anyways
archbishop raheem is also there and he
has prison filled over the area as well
episode six all the kids cried like
little [ __ ] because rimuru is heading
back to the tempest nation well heading
back rimro senses a presence so he
requests ranga to hide in his shadow
the great sage skill comes online and
tells him that he's been caught in a
barrier that would prevent him from
leaving
zoe's body double briefly shows up to
warn roomaru that there are enemies
nearby and that he should flee he gets
caught up in another barrier that would
prevent him from using magic but thanks
to his resist ability he can still use
magic
it's just going to be hindered his an
approach by a new character and hinata
sakaguchi who is the chief knight of the
imperial guard and captain of the holy
knights of the holy empire of rubrios
hinata says some [ __ ] about wanting to
destroy the tempest nation so obviously
rimaru has to die
meanwhile back in the tempest nation
everybody is losing their fights to
their respective opponents because they
can't use their full strength thanks to
the barriers stripping them of their
magic
anyways back over to hinata and rimaru
hinata attacks rimaru claiming that he
is the monster responsible for killing
shizu rimro makes a counter claim saying
that he knew
shizu and that she had asked him to find
and help hinata well arguing rimuru
finds out that he not as informant knew
that he was japanese
the great sage uses the unique ability
to generate to isolate the superior
spirit e3 as a pure spirit this allows
raimiro to summon eat fruit to help him
out in the fight
he not his unique ability usurper allows
her to steal her opponent's abilities
but because there was a magic circuit
between eatfree and rimroo eatfree was
not stolen
feeling like ramiro has no way out he
decides that he needs to use his
gluttony ability
in the last scene as he gives the order
to the great sage to activate his
gluttony ability he loses consciousness
episode 7. rimaru takes on a form
specialized for combat incorporating the
traits of various objects
and monsters hinata launches a bunch of
powerful attacks ending with a
disintegration attack that nearly kills
rimaru
turns out rimrou was never actually
fighting her he had eat-free distractors
so that he could create a doppelganger
and then slip away into hiding and avoid
the fight reimu speculates that even
without the barrier he still would have
lost because of hinata's disintegration
attack
once the fight had concluded rimu tries
teleporting to the tempest nation but
can't do to the barrier they have to
settle for teleporting nearby where they
run into some side characters and
explain the situation the great sage
analyzes the barrier and tells him that
it's anti-magic area
this is similar to the barrier that
hinata was using but it's an inferior
version
rimroot has sowe with going and finding
who's erecting the barrier while he goes
to find who's using this great magic
we then hop on over to benimaru who is
trying to get to and kill miulan because
she had sabotaged their magic
both grucias and yom are trying to
prevent him from doing so
rumor gets there in time to intervene
and agrees to hear her out after what
she had done
she tells him that she's prepared to
accept responsibility for the carnage
that she had caused and he doesn't
understand what she's talking about so
she has to take him to show him she
takes him to where a handful of goblins
were being kept after they were killed
in the
attack rimuru reflects back on his words
from season 1 ordering them not to kill
any humans which is part of the reason
that they didn't defend themselves and
were killed mulan is trying her best to
upset rimaru into killing her
and leaving everybody else out of it he
stays calm and wants to hear her out so
everybody needs to have a conference
after gathering all the details rimrou
comes to the conclusion that the western
holy church and the kingdom of falmouth
had been colluding from the start
neil meyer chimes in and says that the
reasoning is because the western church
doesn't like monsters and falmouth wants
to keep their trade to themselves
rimro then requests that mueller mire go
to the kingdom of blumen and tell them
about the current situation and the
imminent threat from falmuth and
in the last scene mulan comes clean
about serving the demon lord
claiming episode 8 she explains that
clayman's overall goal is to get the
tempest nation and the kingdom of
thalamus to go to war with one another
rimuru decides to postpone miolan's
punishment and instead just imprisons
her for now
rimro is then informed by benny marrow
that shion and gobzo were both
killed in the fighting while trying to
protect the innocent no more big tits
resting on his little jello head
that's when the three adventures from
season one show up looking for rimaru
they tell him that although unlikely
there is a fairy
tale about bringing the dead back to
life so i had discovered the western
holy church's forces
all camped around the city and each camp
is guarding a magic device
but anyways back to the revival thing
where aaron tells reru a story about a
girl and a dragon
the girl was the daughter of a human and
a dragon and of course they don't go
into any nitty-gritty details about the
night she was conceived but
i bet it's a [ __ ] hell of a story she
was raised as a dragon princess then one
day papa dragon made
a double of himself in the form of a
baby dragon and this adorable little
[ __ ] dragon ended up becoming her
companion but things kind of get shitty
when the king tries to take control over
the dragon princess and
ends up killing the little baby
companion dragon in the process
the girl gets a tiny bit emotional and
decides to go full john wick on the king
and his entire nation after she was done
slaughtering tens of thousands of
innocent people she had transformed into
a demon lord when she had transformed
the baby dragon miraculously came back
to life the tiny drawback to that is the
dragon had lost its soul in the process
so when it came back it was an evil
monster that destroyed everything in its
path this dragon became known as the
chaos dragon
the first thing the girl did as a demon
lord was seal away her once beloved
companion
rumors states that there's no point in
bringing him back to life if they don't
have a soul so why bother
aaron goes on to explain that the city
is still surrounded by a barrier
she speculates that this barrier is
actually preventing the souls from
leaving there's like a three percent
chance that this actually works but you
have to remember that shion has big tits
so in anime talk that's basically 99
percent
we also find out the fun fact that aaron
is actually erin grimwald and is a
princess woo
after the talk we learned from the great
sage that rimaru has already acquired
the demon lord seed
he had acquired the seed when he
defeated the orc disaster in season one
so now all he has to do is meet the
conditions and he can evolve into a true
demon lord
the minimum amount of nourishment
required to have the seeds sprout is
around
ten thousand human souls that
conveniently segues into rimu finding
out that the falmouth forces are
marching on the tempest nation with
twenty thousand men rumuru comes in and
tells mulan that she's gonna have to die
and so she gets up and kisses yom and is
prepared to go willingly
turns out rumor is kind of a dick to
everybody because he was never actually
planning on killing her but on the plus
side it was kind of elaborate wingman
and because yom did get a kiss
the artificial heart that clayman gave
to miulan to keep her alive was actually
a bug
this allowed him to spy on her and by
destroying this rimroom makes clayman
think that miulan is dead
rimiro had made an artificial heart of
his own and replaced it so that she
could stay alive
not only does this save her life but now
she is free from clayman's rule as well
when asked what she's gonna do with her
newfound freedom she basically says that
she's gonna [ __ ] young rumro also
informs everybody that he's planning on
killing all of the forces coming here
from falmouth this includes the
king and all of his top officers so once
they're all dead he's going to need
somebody to replace the king yom gets
the news that he is the one
up for promotion and he's going to be
placed as king of falmuth once
everybody's dead
episode nine rimrou says that he'll take
care of the main force heading towards
them while the others are assigned to
take out the magic devices forming the
barriers
shuna and miulan are assigned to replace
the barrier once it's taken down so that
they can keep the souls inside in the
last couple of scenes we see that
everybody is going to fulfill their
proper role and the plan
episode 10. manny maru gabiru and sowei
had all gone to the sites that they were
assigned wiped out the soldiers and
destroyed the devices
meanwhile geld gap dahakuru and rigard
are assigned to attack the camp where
the three other worlders are stationed
geld scores up to take on shogu while
hakuro goes to fight kyoya
kyoyo's skill all-seeing eye allows him
to detect all
motion around him at 300 times the
normal speed so he's pretty confident
he's gonna take on hakuro as anybody
might guess hakuro is still moving way
faster than that he uses this insane
speed to decapitate kyoya
and makes him think back on all of his
evil deeds as he's dying
but anyways we're gonna hop back on over
to geld and shogu
guild uses his wrought abilities so
shogo is on the back foot and as gal
goes to kill him hakuro makes his
appearance
he shows shogu that he had killed kyoya
already and that he's next jogo of
course banneks like a little [ __ ] and
then tries to run off to find kirara who
he kills
in order to gain this survivor ability
this does [ __ ] nothing he just gets
his ass kicked by geld and then
regenerates all the damage he took so he
could get his ass kicked again
after dealing a fair bit of punishment
gel decides that he's going to finish
the job but then a new character
in rosin steps in to stop him rusin
deters the attack and then escapes with
shogo using his teleportation
they had no choice but to let him go
because hakuru states that he had rigged
himself with nuclear strike magic
and his death was acting as the trigger
all four magical devices around the city
are destroyed so shuna and myulan
replaced the barrier with one of their
own
now that that's taking care of rimro
prepares to take out the army and
transform into a true demon lord but
before that can happen we hop back on
over to shogu and rosin
rozen says that he's going to heal shogu
but then ends up killing his soul
instead he then transfers his own soul
into shogo's body and takes on his
abilities as well this makes him the
most powerful majin in falmouth's
history
and maybe even on par with the demon
lord and in the last couple of scenes we
see that rimuru is racking up his insane
kill streak rapidly approaching his 10
000
necessary souls episode 11. ramiroo is
using an
anti-magic barrier over the area where
the army is located so nobody can
teleport to escape they're basically
fishing a barrel at this point so he
kills rosin and this procs the king to
try and enter negotiations with him the
king suggests that the declaration of
war was actually a misunderstanding and
he's wanting to be friends
on top of that he requests that rimuru
pay compensation for their losses and
then they can enter negotiations so
rimuru blows off the dude's arm
right after that rimiro gets the unique
skill merciless
this means that if somebody loses their
will to fight in the face of that skill
they
end up dying the acquisition of the new
skill is nice or whatever but he's only
at 57 percent
of the required number of souls that he
needs to complete the transformation
reimu uses his new merciless skill which
harvests the souls of all the humans
nearby
now that rimro has collected enough
souls he begins his evolution into a
demon lord the drawback to this is that
he gets super tired so he summons ranga
to protect him because he can't fight in
this state
rumor then removes the anti-magic
barrier and uses all of the nearby
bodies to summon three demons one of
which is black
because rimuru is transforming into a
demon lord black and the other two
demons are wanting to serve him this
isn't the only perk to him transforming
as all of his other followers are going
to receive perks
as well ranga gets rimuru the archbishop
and king back to everybody else where
they take the prisoners into custody
he then undergoes the transformation
where he turns from a slime into a demon
slime
because of this all of his physical
abilities have significantly improved we
then get a series of skill
transformations first off the great sage
requests to evolve into words of the
world
it doesn't really show the outcome to
that one but then he gets the skill
wise one wise one then attempts to
evolve when attempting to evolve wise
one it fails continuously while the
great sage tries over and over the great
sage then takes a different approach by
sacrificing the degenerate skill in
order to upgrade the wise one skill this
finally makes the evolution successful
and it turns into an ultimate skill
called raphael
rumuru then decides to sacrifice his
merciless ability to
upgrade his gluttony ability this
evolves the gluttony skill into another
ultimate skill called beelzebub after
all that [ __ ] we hopped back on over
to rosin who was still inside of shogo's
body and survived thanks to his survivor
ability he then comes face to face with
black and the other two demons
black is kind of humiliating this guy so
he decides to put an anti-magic barrier
and fight him hand-to-hand
this should be an advantage for rosin
because he still has shogo's berserker
ability but he's still getting his ass
kicked which makes him come to the
conclusion that it's possible that black
is a primordial i guess ross had died
i'm not really sure his eyes just get
super small that he passes out or some
[ __ ] and then black says it's over so i
guess it's over the harvest festival
transformation that rimuru was
undergoing finally completes and so it's
time to bestow the gifts onto those
connected to him this causes all of his
followers to get stronger but they pass
out in the process
he then uses his belt bob ability to
collect all of the magic kills nearby
using the magic kills he plans to
resurrect all of his allies that were
killed the problem is that he still
doesn't have enough magicals so he
prepares to expend his own life energy
and substitution black suggests the
alternative of using the two demons that
had come with him as a substitution
instead of reamer's life energy now that
he has enough energy he can begin the
secret art of spirit resurrection
in the last couple of scenes rimrou
completes the resurrection and then he
passes out
episode 12. we then hop on back up to
the present where rimuru regains
consciousness with shion alive and well
we also learned that rimuru's followers
had all evolved along with his great
sage ability which had transformed into
raphael
we then hopped back a bit to where malim
had gone to urazania she declares war on
carrion and all of his people
carrion doesn't want to get everybody
involved with the battle because they'll
likely die so he decides that he's going
to fight malim alone while everybody
else retreats to the juror forest
during the fight we see that demon lord
frey had teamed up with malim to fight
against carrion she attacks carrion from
behind taking him by surprise and
kills him the entirety of eurasania is
wiped out due to malim's power but they
did manage to get all the citizens to
safety
rimuru agrees to take in the refugees
and give them a place to stay
they all speculate that it's outside of
malim's nature to fight dirty like that
so something else might be going on
after the fight had concluded demon lord
frey was seen flying towards clayman's
domain
but anyways we hop on over to black who
makes a formal request to stick around
and serve rimaru rimaru agrees to this
and since now he's his new follower he
gives him the name diablo
bestowing the name of course drains
magic kills but it takes a little bit
more than rimro was expecting
even though his magic kills had grown
tenfold since his evolution he still
loses half of them while bestowing the
name meaning that diablo is probably
going to be popping off in future
episodes reimu then reflects on the
upcoming challenges there is the
inevitable showdown with clayman the
aftermath dealing with the kingdom of
falmuth
and of course the western holy church
who are still going to be gunning for
them
raphael then chimes in to state that it
might not be as hard as he thinks
this is because of the appraisal of
unlimited imprisonment which is the
ability that's keeping valdora sealed
away
is almost complete raphael speculates
that once valdora is free that'll keep
the western powers in check
once the appraisal is complete rimrou
creates a body double for veldora to
inhabit
and in the last couple of scenes valdora
inhabits the body which turns him into a
blonde stud
i'm going to be doing the future seasons
and you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all of that time i got
reincarnated as the slime videos in the
playlist on the right side you can also
find the links in the description below
and the only thing i hate more than
intros is outros
you